no we're not happy uh the this
stop go stop approach to travel is
bonkers
uh portugal has exactly the same covered
case rates and higher vaccination rates
when it was taken off the uk's green
list last week that it had when it went
on it
malta which has higher vaccination rates
than the uk
and only one-third of the cobalt case
rates can't get from the ambulance to
the green list
the whole thing is it is a shambles and
it's typical of boris johnson's
government just making this stuff up as
they go along
there is no green list and what we keep
calling for in the travel industry is
now that we have 80 of the adult
population of britain vaccinated
why can't those people go on holidays to
portugal spain without restrictions
they're already vaccinated because i
suppose the argument would be that they
could still give
they could still contract covid and give
it to someone else
the percentage of people who are
vaccinated contracting covert is
minuscule
the risk to public health is equally
minuscule one of the great
things about the success of the uk's
vaccine problem is yes well there's a
rise in case numbers particularly the
indian variant
the vaccine is effective against the
variant there has been no rise in
hospitalizations are serious illnesses
are thankfully deaths so we're locking
our generous johnson
trying to lock up the british public for
no i mean
for no good reason other than they can
there's no public health reason okay
reports in the paper this morning
suggesting that the foreign office had
actually advised to keep portugal
on the green list what do you think was
going on there
and they also recommended adding water
to it
so you know one leg of government
doesn't know what the other legal
government is doing and you've got to
come back he come back to the
fundamental point
80 of the uk adult population is now has
received at least one dose of the
vaccine
why can't they travel to europe and come
back and much more importantly from
a uk economy point of view and certainly
from the london economy
why can't european irish and european
visitors who have been vaccinated
come to london it's all very well for
robert generic and you know george uses
to say they're going to take their
holidays in cornwall or in scotland
they're not going to take their
staycations in london the you know
fast sways of london depends on tourism
it depends on you are irish and european
visitors coming to london during june
july and august
to get those people back to work and
this government has no plan
for allowing vaccinated visitors into
london it makes no sense
certainly no public health sense and
it's just more boris johnson
screwing it up as he goes along we saw
the front page of the times
this morning reflecting on our interview
with george eustis yesterday referring
to it as a model
who knows what's what's going to happen
next what is the
ramification for the airline business if
this continues
i mean you know i think less so for the
airline business kit you know we are
we're taking lots of bookings from uk
passengers in july and into august you
know everybody accepts that the
restrictions will be gone by the time we
get to peak summer
but it's very difficult for us as an
industry and also for the rest of the
wider tourism industry
to plan for june to plan for the first
half of july
do we bring more people back from
furlough do we re-employ them
do we schedule the flights we can't
change the fights then cancel them
within two weeks because we have to pay
compensation to customers so
it's incredibly difficult we'll get
through this the airline industry will
get through this but
the real challenge here is how do you
get the rest of london and britain's
tourism industry back to work
because it fundamentally depends on
welcoming back european visitors
who by the end of june 60 of the
european adult population
will have been vaccinated and yet the uk
is saying we're closed
don't come here you've got to quarantine
why if you've had the vaccine you have
to quarantine
and in the uk why if you're vaccinated
can you not go on holidays to malta or
portugal
who have lower covert case rates than
the uk
it makes no sense it's not just a model
it's a complete
cock-up where do you think the prime
minister should go on holiday this year
i think you should go to portugal spain
uh greece or italy
enjoy the sun on the beach covet free
like many millions of british families
will do
certainly through july and august and he
should clearly travel ryanair
okay do you hold out any hope at all uh
michael o'leary of popular destinations
being added to that green list
this summer i think look
it's inevitable that portugal spain
greece and italy will be added to that
list
in july and in august there is simply no
medical basis
for maintaining these travel
restrictions when 80
of your population is vaccinated and
when 60 of the european population is
vaccinated
the hospitals are empty thankfully the
icus are empty
it is time to continue the recovery and
we would call on the government
to stick to their 21 due dates and get
on with it the vaccines are working
we the people of england are britain now
deserve their vaccine bonus
uh and what would you say to the prime
minister he says i'm very sorry mr
o'leary but
your planes uh will not be carrying
british passengers
to mainland europe anytime soon
i suspect his uh voters and the
population of the uk
will ignore him and they will have the
medical basis for ignoring him because
they'll be vaccinated
and the question i would put to prime
minister johnson is if 80
of your people are vaccinated why are
you not allowing them to go on holidays
to spain and portugal where
covered case races are lower than they
are in the uk